[Musique]
au vu de presse avec vos bilal tarabet
bonjour bilal bonjour si nous commençons
par la finlande qui a demandé hier
d'adhérer à l'otan ce pays neutre depuis
la seconde guerre mondiale a pourtant
changé posture à cause de l'invasion en
ukraine mais justement l'ukraine
elle-même demande à adhérer à l'alliance
depuis plusieurs années exactement et
c'est d'ailleurs la question que pose le
new york times je cite le titre de
l'article pourquoi pas l'ukraine et plus
précisément toujours dans l'article
pourquoi pas cette démocratie corrompue
imparfaite mais aussi héroïque et bien
justement le rappelle le new york times
quand l'ukraine a fait de son adhésion à
l'otan une priorité nationale en 2019
elle a même changé sa constitution pour
ça le pays était considéré il ya
quelques années trop gangréné par la
corruption et avec des institutions
démocratiques trop faible pour
représenter une candidature sérieuse
avant plusieurs années alors évidemment
depuis l'invasion russe ça a changé mais
les membres de l'alliance atlantique
cette fois n'évoque plus la corruption
mais simplement une volonté d'éviter un
embrasement général c'est l'ukraine
intègre le temps et éventuellement une
troisième guerre mondiale les prennent à
coire est un sujet dont on parle peu
bilal il concerne ce soldat russe qui
refusent d'aller se battre le guardian
britannique a rencontré des soldats
russes qui sont allés en ukraine mais
qui ont refusé d'y retourner alors
pourquoi je cite pour ne pas finir dans
un cercueil sauf que ces soldats se sont
aperçus qu'ils pouvaient simplement
refusé d'aller en russie puisque on l'a
déjà dit la russie n'est pas
officiellement en guerre contre
l'ukraine mais elle mène une opération
spéciale du coup les soldats qui
refusent d'y aller ne sont pas
considérés comme des déserteurs s'ils
disent non ils sont tout simplement
réaffectés dans d'autres bases ailleurs
en russie le commentaire d'un de ses
soldats qui a donc refusé de retourner
en ukraine à part être furieux il n'y a
pas grand chose que mes supérieurs
pouvaient faire on va changer
radicalement de sujets bilal tarabet on
va évoquer
ce quelque chose en va des airs qui a
fait la une de plusieurs quotidiens
hier absolument et on le voit ici à la
une du figaro entre autres cette photo
c'est la première photo du trou noir qui
trône au milieu de notre galaxie et qui
répond au doux nom de sagittarius a
alors bien évidemment c'est un exploit
technique qui a requis le travail
simultanés nous explique le quotidien
d'une dizaine des plus grands télescopes
du monde pour photographier un objet qui
en réalité est minuscule à l'échelle de
la galaxie alors ça ça fait un peu
plusieurs fois plusieurs millions de
voix par dont la taille du soleil mais
si la voie lactée étaient représentées
sur un poster qui fait 10 km de long ce
trou noir représente la marque que
ferait une toute petite épingle au
milieu donc on voit bien la difficulté
de la chose qu'est ce qu'on voit ici et
bien on voit donc un trou noir au milieu
et les particules de lumière qui tourne
autour avant d'être absorbé
on voit cette photo mais évidemment il
ya une question qui n'est toujours pas
résolue qu'est ce qu'il y a dans le trou
noir voir derrière je vous laisse poser
la question elle et on passera à autre
chose aux vielles sur terre modestement
on parle tennis on parle de rafael nadal
déçu sorti prématurément du tournoi de
rome on est sur terre battue sa surface
favorite exactement on est sur terre
battue sa surface favorite alors rafael
nadal évoque évoque même une tristesse
ans au delà d'une déception parce que
l'espagnol n'est pas sorti sur blessure
mais presque c'est son éternel douleur
au pied gauche qu'il a qui l'a empêché
de jouer à son niveau le quotidien
sportif l'équipe rappelle que rafael
nadal est atteint d'un syndrome
extrêmement rare le syndrome de müller
weiss c'est une déformation osseuse au
niveau du pied extrêmement rare je les
dis qu'ils provoquent des douleurs
parfois très très forte lorsqu'on pose
le pied par terre alors il est à la
tristesse mais il ya aussi l'inquiétude
puisque
le tournoi de roland garros démarre ici
à paris pas très loin d'ici d'ailleurs
dans dix jours commentaire de rafael
nadal qui est le recordman de victoires
à roland garros la première chose que je
dois atteindre c'est de ne pas avoir mal
en m'entraînant ce jeudi ce n'était pas
possible de jouer pour moi mais
peut-être que dans deux jours les choses
iront mieux enfin le mot du jour bilal
alors le mot du jour c'est para para
para para para accès je n'y arrivais
paraskevidékatriaphobie bon bref c'est
ça veut dire la peur du vendredi 13 car
nous sommes ça vient du grec à 20,42
sommes bien le vendredi 13 mai et le
quotidien régional la voix du nord nous
explique pourquoi certaines personnes
souffrent 2 paraskevas bref folie alors
il ya d'abord la scène dans la bible
dernier dîner de jésus-christ treize
convives à table dont judas qui l'a
trahie et jésus christ et crucifié le
lendemain qui était un vendredi mais
aussi dans la mythologie nordique
scandinave loki le dieu de la malice et
de la discorde est invité lui aussi
décidément à dîner par le roi des dieux
aux dents mais il tue le fils d'odin et
l'eau qui était le 13e convives dans ce
dîner enfin pour les grecs et les
romains le chiffre parfait c'est 12' les
douze dieux de l'olympe les douze
travaux d'hercule les 12 signes du
zodiaque et donc le xiii vient casser
cette perfection alors sachez juste
assez une information que je vous donne
comme ça gratuitement que pour les plus
braves d'entre vous qui s'aventureraient
à prendre un avion vendredi 13 les
billets sont environ 30 % moins cher je
ne suis absolument pas part à ce qu'est
vtt etc merci beaucoup